matthew mcconaughey's shocking new
tell-all it's crazy
rachel smith spoke to him from nashville
that's right vevica and kev
now the book is called green lights and
matthew sheds light on the serious
traumas he faced before he became
alright all right all right you do not
hold anything back
you said that you encountered a
situation where you were molested by a
man at 18 you were knocked unconscious
out of the van then you were also
blackmailed into losing your virginity
at 15 15.
yeah you know i don't go into great
detail on those two particular stories
and
and i don't for good reason i haven't
really carried those hardships with me
they haven't interrupted who i've become
and i think part of that's because at
the time when they happened i was very
clear
that they were wrong matthew's real life
story is as compelling as his movie
roles
the oscar winner who has shared the
screen with j.lo pete hudson and sandra
bullock
admits to crashes with co-stars but has
a rule against dating them
i think it's so interesting that you
never dated a co-star
because look we see it all the time in
hollywood here to
indulge us with who some of those
crushes were made
no that's a great question but no not
your business
but we actually recently chatted with
kate hudson i
have yet to have the kiss with matthew
that's just like
kind of simple they're always a
windstorm or a rainstorm or
go under water or why in the middle kiss
fall off the stairs it was always some
kind of prank to it
matthew fans went crazy when camilla
posted a photo of levi
the two of them were cooking in the
kitchen oh my gosh
it's a mini matthew right there he's
becoming a good buddy of mine
now as he's getting reaching 12. i want
to take a little trip down memory lane
show you a clip i do believe it's from
1993.
it's american dream isn't it yes angels
in the outfield forty eight thousand
five hundred dollars for me to go to
oakland
and play baseball for ten weeks i was
like i'd do this for free
and i've tried to you know continually
that's part of my
decision-making paradigm i've never done
a film that i
actually wouldn't have done for free
what an incredible outlook to have on
his craft and can you believe it just 20
years later
he went on to win an academy award for
dallas buyers club
you